this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development and now I would like to
introduce you to carissa little that
who's the director of programs at the
Stanford center for professional
development thank you so much Tanja good
morning I'd like to get started this
morning by introducing my esteemed
colleagues first we have dr. Tamra
Carlton camera is a Stanford alumnus and
founder and CEO of the innovation
leadership board LLC he works closely
with organizations around the world to
analyze develop and foster best
practices and innovation she is the
fellow of the foundation for enterprise
development and a fellow of the Bay Area
science and innovation consortium Tamara
brings over a decade of industry
experience in corporate strategy
technology development and marketing
roles that startups and large companies
she recently edited a collection called
sustaining innovation collaboration
models for a complex world welcome Tamra
next I'd like to introduce dr. William
Cockayne bill is a consulting associate
professor at Stanford and leads our
foresight and innovation program he
teaches emerging technologies and
innovation strategy within the School of
Engineering a seasoned entrepreneur bill
is the founder and CEO of hand stand
which is developing new products for the
mobile market bill has held senior roles
and technology research and product
development at Apple daimler-benz and
eastman kodak he holds multiple patents
and has many publications including the
book mobile asians welcome bill and
finally we have lauren rogers lauren is
the executive director of the national
center for employee ownership he has
been working in employee ownership since
1995 before joining the n CEO in 2005
Lauren was a senior principal at
ownership associates an employee
ownership consulting firm in Cambridge
Massachusetts where he worked for 10
years Lauren specializes in equity
compensation plans and employee stock
ownership plans ESO p.s including best
management practices in plans
line communications employee involvement
governance management and organizational
culture he works with firms worldwide
and speaks and publishes extensively on
topics including employee motivation
open book management employee education
organization dynamics and business
literacies welcome Lauren and now I'd
like to turn the floor over to Tamara
Carl Thank You Carissa bill Lauren and I
are very glad to be here to talk with
you about exporting innovation
particularly looking at some of the
issues and challenges about translating
Silicon Valley's culture in China so in
terms of our agenda for today we're
really looking to dive deep into
understanding different forms of equity
compensation and their related pros and
cons and with that best practices in the
design and implementation and looking to
see how this might ultimately translate
or be adapted for the Chinese culture so
we'll start actually covering with the
basics of employee ownership and I'll
hand off to Lauren to talk to highlight
here great thank you so much Tamara so
I'll try to give you a very good basic
overview of what employee ownership
looks like to some extent in the United
States and to some extent the potential
for it in anywhere it might exist so we
want to start with this very simple
question of what is employee ownership
I've done my best to put a definition on
the top line of this slide which is that
a substantial portion of a company's
employees have an ownership interest in
the company and this is a intentionally
extremely vague definition what is
substantial and what's an ownership
interest and I think the answer to that
is that there's a whole spectrum in fact
several dimensions of employee ownership
so we talked about employee ownership
we're not talking about a yes/no
dichotomous question we're talking about
a range of how many employees how much
of the company what formed the rights
and ownership interests those employees
hold a has in the company and you can
certainly imagine
you don't even have to imagine there are
a number of public companies where
employees have an interest in one
percent of the shares and there are
companies that are work our own
cooperatives where employees have a
hundred percent of the ownership and
complete governance authority over the
entire company so the range of employee
ownership is extremely broad in practice
employee ownership tends to concern
corporations S corporations and C
corporations in the United States mainly
because those are companies with stock
now this is mostly in practice not in
theory there's certainly no reason that
limited liability companies or other
forms of organization can't be employee
owned and in fact one of the trends that
we're beginning to see emerge at the
National Center for employee ownership
is that more people are starting to look
up the our book on employee ownership in
limited liability companies so I think
this may be diversifying a little bit in
the United States and of course there
are sorts of other ways to think about
this I had a summer internship at an
undergraduate where I went to Ukraine to
work with employee owned companies and
it turned out that my eye contact there
when he was talking about employee owned
companies he was talking about sole
proprietorships where people were
selling chocolate cigarettes and coffee
from little kiosks on the sidewalk and
they were employee-owned because there
was a single employee and that employee
owned the whole teahouse in practice
though employee ownership in the United
States is a quite broad part of the
economy about thirty six percent of
people say that they say that they own
stock at the 36 of people who work for
companies that have stock say that they
own shares and about twenty four percent
of people who work for corporations
corporations with stock say that they
have stock options now this is from the
general social survey which is a broad
representation of the US workforce and
it didn't verify their answers so it
could well be that people don't know
exactly what they own so this this is a
general number but you can see that the
perception of employee ownership is
quite widespread and in the United
States and and the reality is certainly
somewhere in that ballpark even if these
numbers are not
completely accurate just briefly about a
national center for employee ownership
is a nonprofit organization we're
primarily dedicated to research into
serving our members and our mission is
to provide accurate unbiased information
about employee ownership we've been
around for just over 30 years now and
we're based in Oakland California let me
share with you some research highlights
some of this is from research that we
have done ourselves and some of it is
from research that that we've monitored
that other folks have been doing the
people number of people who say that
they own shares and the companies where
they work that thirty-six percent number
i shared with you earlier has been
relatively stable between 2006 and 2010
despite the dramatic changes in the
economy the number of holding options
has had a slight decrease from 2006 to
2010 a sharper decrease for the four
years prior to 2006 but it still does
remain a significant portion of the
economy significant portion of the
workforce stock purchase plans which
we'll talk a little bit about how those
work remain a significant part of public
companies including companies that have
significant presence both in the United
States and overseas our current estimate
for the number of employee stock
ownership plans or Aesop's is that there
are just under 11,000 plans with of just
over 10 million participants they're the
easiest form of employee ownership to
document in the United States there has
been some fascinating research that's
just come out in the past couple months
about employee ownership and its
performance impact much of that has been
done by Joseph palazzi at Rutgers
University with Doug Cruz also at
Rutgers and Richard Freeman at Harvard
and what this research has found is
consistent with what's existed before
but it has been able to put a little bit
more of a quantitative accuracy on this
and a little bit more definitive
research that employee ownership tends
to have employee owned companies that
have an ownership culture by which we
mean come
use that act as you would expect an
employee-owned company to act by
involving people in decisions by keeping
people informed tend to have higher
returns on equity tend to have faster
employment growth lower turnover both
voluntary and involuntary as it turns
out and more engaged workforces there's
a lot more depth that we can go into on
this research that we will do the basics
here let me talk very briefly about some
of the main forms of employee ownership
and for some of these I'll use the US
terms but these are all forms that are
applicable and in any context after I've
done this I'll talk about the main
parameters that define employee
ownership and then show how some of
these different forms fit on those
parameters so the first is direct
ownership where employees or anybody
simply own shares that they may have
purchased or owned as founders or in
some ways simply hold a share
certificate another way is there are
texts qualified plans aesop's employee
stock ownership plans and 401k plans
that hold company shares those are both
tax qualified employee benefit plans
that are that are as in the united
states governed by the employee
retirement income security act and are
quite heavily regulated another form is
stock options there are different forms
of stock options of course those can be
incentive stock options which are
legally regulated or non-qualified stock
options which are far more flexible
there are restricted stock and
restricted stock is where companies give
employees actual real bona fide shares
but they have restrictions and if those
restrictions are not met then those that
stock is forfeited and the employees
lose them a close cousin of that is the
company offers restricted stock units
which is a promise to give stock if the
conditions are met it works almost the
same as restricted stock but you don't
get this year as if you if you don't be
if you fail to meet the criteria rather
than forfeiting the shares that you
already have another interesting concept
is a synthetic equity which is a
contract that works a lot like shares
but doesn't actually involve any real
Sheriff at all for example of a share of
phantom stock what gives me the right to
have the value of a share of stock
without
actually owning that stock a stock
appreciation right would give me the
right to have an amount of value equal
to the increase in the price of share
over time without actually ever getting
a share of stock the advantage of this
of synthetic equity is simplicity it's
basically just a cash bonus where you
have a formula that's based on stock
price to determine the value of the
bonus then last we have in store
employee stock purchase plans and in the
United States this is one of the few
ways that employees purchase shares by
Allah gating their own cash to to
acquire shares usually in the form of a
deferral of payroll so those are the
main forms some of the key parameters in
defining how employee ownership is
designed and for those of you who are
thinking of creating a company and of
making it in play on door having some
level of equity compensation or for
those of you who are already in a
company that have some level of employee
ownership and these are the these are
the things that you'll want to think
about to make sure that you've developed
a good fit for your company now of
course everybody has their own list of
key parameters to me this is the list
that covers the important things in
theory and in practice without going
into too much detail but everybody will
have their own list you want to look at
how much of the workforce is it your
entire workforce is it just the
management team that is it down two or
three layers layers if it everybody
who's been at the company for a year if
it is it something that changes over
time where you have a periodic grant so
the longer you've been there the more
you get another question is how much of
the company now clearly the range here
is from one percent or even less all the
way to a hundred percent of the
company's shares can be held by
employees and there is no right answer
but there are clearly a whole bunch of
wrong answers everybody is likely
familiar with the challenges that
Facebook has faced recently where they
issued enough shares early on that now
they're having to ask for employees to
give some of their shares back other
companies have run into problems where
they gave so few shares that they simply
seemed irrelevant to most employees so
the question of how much of the company
is it a fat
nating one and one that I'd be happy to
talk to you more about if people are
interested the next question is stock or
stock linked will people actually ever
actually own a share of stock or will
they have a value that in cash that's
linked to the value of stock this is the
same as the question of whether it's an
actual plan or a phantom plan as we
talked about before next question is how
much if anything does an employee paid
to become an owner the number of the
plans are pure accompanied contribution
employee stock ownership plans stock
appreciation rights there's no a lot of
pocket expense for employees at all
other plans such as employee soft
purchase plans and stock options plan do
require employees to pay some of their
own cash none of our question is how is
the ownership allocated among employees
and this is another very interesting
question do we give more employees who
have been there longer more shares do we
give people who have higher compensation
do we give our high performers
regardless of their level in the
organization do we have it the formula
based or is it something that's going to
be management or board discretion we've
seen companies end up with all sorts of
allocation patterns some for the people
in their workforces and it's thinking
this through is one of the most
interesting aspects of employee
ownership because it involves not just
multiple questions of fairness both
inside the company and relative to
people in similar positions outside the
company but also questions of time and
if we have an allocation formula or an
allocation process is this something
that's going to be fair from year 1 to
year 5 or will we need to change how
those shares or stock rights are
allocated over time what are the
conditions are limits in the context of
talking about restricted stock I
mentioned some of the possibilities
there you can set conditions for when
people receive a grant of shares or
share rights you can set conditions for
when people forfeit rights that they
already have you can set conditions for
how long they have to hold on to shares
after they've been rewarded or after
restrictions have left they're all sore
of conditions that can fit under this
category it's a very broad one and these
conditions could be performance-based
they could be based on the individual
meeting certain performance targets they
could be based on a department meeting
certain performance target the company
reaching certain performance targets
they may also be based on a changes of
control provision in the company such as
going public there are all sorts of ways
that these conditions changed
fundamentally than nature of employee
ownership and the incentive effect that
it has another question is how employees
sell their ownership interest who makes
the market if employees own shares with
other employees is it the company itself
if the company's public then there's
obviously a ready market for any shares
that employees own but if the company's
private this can be a very interesting
question do we want to allow employees
to sell their shares to people who are
not employees does the company has a
right of first refusal and how do we set
the price at which those shares will
work we're currently working with a
company where employees were able to buy
shares from the company whenever the
company issued new shares at a thirty
percent discount and nobody did it
despite the very generous discount
because they didn't have anybody to sell
them to nobody would be interested in
buying shares at full price from an
employee because they can always get
those shares at a thirty percent
discount straight from the company so
the next question is the impact on
governance and here again the range is
quite broad in theory there are a number
of extremely successful work around
cooperatives that have full governance
rights held by employees and phantom
plans have no governance impact at all
employees of no governance rights
there's also the governance question of
getting in shareholders to approve the
design of an equity compensation plan
let's touch briefly on this in this
ninth question how is stock valued
companies do have a quite high degree of
discretion and how they value their
shares some use Book value or a very
simple formula others
are required to have an independent firm
value their shares all companies with
employee stock ownership firm plans are
required to have an outside valuation
firm use a fairly extensive market based
method to evaluate their shares annually
the other piece of this evaluation is
how often does the valuation happen is
it something that we're going to do once
a year is it something that will do
quarterly or monthly or whenever
management or the board feels like it
generally the the right answer seems to
be to do it as often as practical as
often as there is some potential
transaction and then the last is changes
in ownership structure this is something
that can that will have a huge impact on
employee ownership and that employee
ownership will have a huge impact on if
we have some current owners of the
company who are interested in getting
out then employee ownership should be
designed to facilitate that exit if we
want to have an owner that is is looking
to completely sell the companies and
that's something that employee ownership
can facilitate if we're looking to have
the owners maintain a majority share
forever and that's something that's
going to affect the amount of employee
ownership and the rate at which it
develops so these are the key parameters
let me take just a minute and I'll do a
very brief job of looking at some of the
different types of employee ownership
and how they lay out on these key
parameters so first let's look at a
non-qualified option plan non-qualified
options are not regulated they're very
very few restrictions on how they're
designed and the tax benefits are
minimal they're treated as a the taxable
event when the options are granted so
here's an example we've got the ten
parameters there on the left-hand column
on the right hand column we've got a
typical example of how a company might
structure a non-qualified stock option
plan now these are for illustration as I
mentioned these can be very very
flexible but as you look through at this
company we've got the top twenty percent
of the workforce receiving options that
are worth about four percent of the
company's shares when they're
when exercised this is actual stock
employees who exercised options will buy
shares and only shares once they
exercise those options the the employee
contribution will be the fair market
value on the date that the options are
issued and valuable receives the fair
market value on the date that they're
exercised this company executives will
decide who gets how many options and the
conditions will be performance-based in
this case they're looking for employees
to reach certain individual performance
targets before they before they're
allowed to exercise their options the
company is promised to provide liquidity
for the use shares and virtually no
impact on governance and there will be a
board approved analysis and the board is
leaving itself flexibility to determine
what that analysis will be in
determining the value of those shares
the change on the ownership structure is
unlikely since it's only four percent of
shares now let's look at a plan which is
almost identical except this is going to
be a phantom plan which is called a
stock appreciation rights plan or sour
plan this plan if you look through this
almost all of the entries on the right
hand side there are identical except for
the second third and fourth lines down
where the value is equal to four percent
of the shares actually the increase in
the value of four percent of the shares
and instead of getting stuck we have a
cash value which is linked to stock the
employee contribution here is none and
all of the other options here under a
stock appreciation rights are exactly
the same as as a non-qualified stock
option again this is just an example of
stock appreciation rights are also
incredibly flexible now just to give you
a very sharp contrast let me tell you
what an employee stock ownership plan
looks like on these ten criteria here
almost all employees are required by
federal law to be participants the
portion of the stock is often up to one
hundred percent because there's a very
attractive tax break for companies that
are one hundred percent owned by a fine
employee stock ownership plan there's
actual stock although it's held by the
trust not directly by employees there's
a trust set up to own shares and
employees or beneficiaries of the trust
employees make no contributions content
allocations are almost always
proportional to compensation twice as
much compensation means twice as much
there's conditions are usually time and
continued employment liquidity for the
four employees is either through the
public market if it's a public company
or the company is legally obligated to
make a market for those shares if it is
privately held there's limited
governance rights as prescribed by
federal law and evaluation is also by
public market or by an independent
outside appraisal the ownership
structure can be fundamentally
transformed by Anissa clearly in the
event of a 100-percent esop owned
company which is a very frequent these
days roughly forty-five percent of these
up companies are a hundred percent owned
by their ease up so very briefly just to
highlight two major issues which we
won't get into which take a little bit
more depth clearly the questions that
that determine what employee ownership
looks like or whether a company is
public or private what kind of text
treatment and the company prioritizes
both for itself and for award recipients
what type of profitability the company
is expecting well company with continued
profit growth it's more likely to look
at an incremental value plan like a
stock option or a stock appreciation
right and then the volatility of
profitability which can make it very
difficult to predict the cost of
different types of plans terrific Lauren
has had a chance to cover some of the
basics of employee ownership overall
highlighting research and developments
within the US but also touching on some
different ways to approach employee
ownership now let's take a regional look
at ownership in Silicon Valley and
understands a little bit about how this
particular region in northern california
approaches employee ownership so for
those who haven't been to Silicon Valley
this is a part of Northern California
that's associated with the high-tech
industry particularly fast business
growth and an entrepreneurial spirit but
this wasn't always the case with Silicon
Valley in many ways the region has
evolved over the years
you know today Silicon Valley is known
for creating working-class millionaires
what some journalists have dubbed the
silicon Aires for you know having
distributed wealth from the work that
they've done in the area but this is
something that actually really began at
the start of or the mid 20th century you
know this was established with companies
such as Fairchild Semiconductor Varian
associates HP and the original premise
was that management wanted to reward and
motivate the implant employees
particularly the engineers and the
scientists who had a direct impact on
building the products and what
management found is that this practice
was effective incentive really excited
and energized the employees gave them a
reason to feel that they were part of a
broader mandate and mission and over the
years this practice evolved to allow the
line workers those who were a part of
the company but may not have direct role
in a new product development to also
become joint owners in that particular
company and so through the 1960s up to
today and management you know gradually
rewarded all employees and now employee
ownership has become a common practice
that really defines Silicon Valley
unlike a lot of other regions around the
world as scholars as well as
practitioners have found that a model of
ownership also influences organizational
culture so the way that equity might be
structured has a way on going to beliefs
and values that employee might hold in
particular employees and workers end up
feeling much more empowered they gain
more input about the decisions that they
make about their work the hierarchy is
flattened and in many cases and when
people think about new companies and
startups in Silicon Valley they often
think of much more distributed team
structure where authority is poor
further down into the ranks you know
yeah leadership clearly plays a role but
you also have a lot of decisions being
made you know at the front lines and
also by all types of employees so that
everybody feels that not only do they
own a piece of the company but they also
have an impact on the kind of work that
they do that ultimately can translate
into company performance and future
growth for that particular product or
service now this paints a picture of
Silicon Valley but the way this region
operates in terms of its employee
ownership doesn't necessarily equate to
other regions or countries around the
world and in particular looking at China
now drawing from the mix of research
studies experts in Chinese business as
well as recent reports there's been a
growing interest in understanding how
China approaches and encourages employee
ownership and really allowing different
workers at all levels to contribute to
the growth of a particular company or
organization now part of the research
shows that this is a recent growth so
back in the 1990's the state-owned
enterprises you know really began to
look at reforming the way that these
organizations were set up and used a
model of employee ownership to
restructure a lot of these particular
developments and by 2001 about seventeen
percent of state-owned enterprises were
either owns completely or partially by
the workers themselves and this started
to generate a lot of interest in stock
options and company stock directly
employee shares became very popular and
part of this actually you know brought
both good and bad to Chinese business so
and again depends on kind of your
interpretation you know but part of the
the tension and I became you know
there's a focus on short-term returns
balanced by looking at ways to grow the
company or an organization long-term you
know particularly for state enterprise
hand in hand with that there
the employers became so popular that
there were illegal trades made on the
black market and other practices that
began to concern the Chinese government
and in the last decade or so the
government policies became more
restrictive in reaction and in
particular there are limits now on
Chinese citizens holding foreign funds
and becoming more involved with foreign
owned enterprises and so there are their
needs you know there's there's clearly a
balance underway about understanding how
to build a employee-owned company within
a Chinese context but also balancing
that with international interest and
practices from revived such as from
Silicon Valley now similar to Silicon
Valley there's also been a change and
growth around the culture of business
entrepreneurship and related to this
many big companies have really tried to
encourage the workers to become more
involved so companies such as Starbucks
bank of china china construction bank
offers stock plans huawei is the
employee-owned entirely and so all of
these you know help influence and create
a growing awareness about the benefits
and the value of being employee-owned
within a Chinese context but of course
some obstacles remain part of it is
related to the funding environment
venture capital is still quite rare in
China most of the funding for new
ventures comes through family friends or
family and also perceptions about an
unstable environment as Chinese
entrepreneurs look at both generating
short-term profits with long-term growth
where do they look to motivate their own
workforce and bring in a lot of these
concepts that they see working very
successfully in other parts of the world
now with that let's take a look at a
specific case of a Silicon Valley
startup so this is based on field
research that that I did looking at a
particular startup
in the tech industry and this particular
company has already built and launched
its first product they have a small
dedicated team mainly based in Silicon
Valley that supplemented with help from
contractors the employee or the
workforce for this particular startup is
it incentivized with stock options which
is a very common practice for Silicon
Valley ventures and as part of this case
the founder and CEO decided that the
Chinese market presented a whole growth
opportunity there was also a fair amount
of interest and looking to China as well
for next steps in business opportunities
and so with the board support to CEO
plans to open its office in China what
I've done is for the purposes of because
teaching the case expanded the real
situation where the CEO which is met a
Chinese national at a local bar this is
something that happens very often in
Silicon Valley where there's a mix of
formal and informal overlapping and at
part of his bar conversation the CEO
wanted to hear some advice from this
other Chinese national who happened to
be a serial entrepreneur when you think
about going outside of Silicon Valley
and transplanting a new company opening
a different office and what are some of
the issues to consider and part of the
conversation at this bar is that in
China there's a perception that you know
foreign jobs or company or jobs coming
from foreign companies will offer more
money and and so as part of it sometimes
the Chinese workers might have more of a
demand that they have the expectation
that they could be offered stock options
or at least some way to contribute a
known part of a company but at the same
time that perception might change based
on that particular that person's role in
an organization for an average worker
the goal might be to find more stability
and address issues for the hearing now
and this could be tied to benefits
related to you know commuting allowance
or health insurance or things along
those lines versus a person at the
senior manager level might be more
interested in long-term opportunities or
the vigour growth that and potential
that the company might offer now you
know part of this conversation and this
is based on you know many trends and
stories and what's happening in China is
that the Silicon Valley way of working
is becoming much more common this is not
something that is a new export as much
as then part of a growing awareness
about other areas and places around the
world working and part of this
recognition is been driven by a group
that kind of is informally known as sea
turtles so those from China who have
studied or worked abroad and has been
returned back to China to create new
enterprises and ventures and bring a lot
of the knowledge back to the country now
you know part of what the CEO of the
startup heard is that there's still some
challenges that remain there's a high
turnover rate often with workers there
are strong traditional Chinese values
that need to be balanced that might
potentially be in conflict with certain
attributes of entrepreneurship you know
related to self initiative a value on
capital growth and such and all of this
are different elements to keep in mind
and as a very kind of simplified
decision framework you can see here some
four options that the CEO could consider
as he looks at taking his company to
China you know what should you consider
very simply the first option is that
every office is the same so therefore
everybody is eligible for the same
equity structure at the same time the
second option is that you do a regional
twist
and part of this allows the startup
management team to adapt to local tax
regulations any cultural needs and you
know provide a little bit more
flexibility to accommodate any
complicated tax or County and reporting
the third option looks more at creating
more of a culture of ownership and puts
less emphasis on the equity itself and
this separates what you might consider
kind of a financial ownership from a
psychological ownership and this really
empowers the local workers to define
what they see as incentives to become
more involved in the company to
encourage participatory decision-making
but of course this creates a challenge
for the startup management team on how
to balance Chinese demands with any
American demands and can still create a
very comprehensive and coherent culture
a unified culture across the entire
company the fourth option looks at a
little bit more of a variation and the
CEO could consider you know does he look
at reliant on part of his Silicon Valley
workforce to actually go to China and
help seed the culture and become more
involved but there's benefits of what
you might call face time and having
everybody meet each other in person and
work together and create a bit of a
complementary team but at the same time
and this approach brings its own
challenges and you know certainly take
staff away from the Silicon Valley
office but it may not allow the Chinese
workforce to grow or flourish as quickly
so certainly pros and cons for all of
these four options there's other options
on the table and what I'd like to do is
not provide to be had the epilogue or
the conclusion for this particular
startup they're still chasing this issue
now and discussing the pros and cons
with the startup board but instead turn
to professor bill Cockayne and have him
talk a little bit about you know this
particular situation from his own
experience so bill you've done a fair
amount of teaching at Stanford but
you're also seasons entrepreneur
maybe you could tell the audience
briefly a little bit about what your
company does I've been out here in
Silicon Valley for about 20 years and as
you heard earlier spent my seminal years
at companies like Apple and Kodak
daimler-benz and many of them had a
employee ownership culture that some
were very blatant like Apple where I had
stock I could pipe by through esop plans
i was given stock at certain bonus
periods and of course i felt very vested
in the company because every friday
afternoon we'd have beer bashes and we'd
get to sit around and chat with each
other and you begin to reach across the
company at the time was only about
10,000 I think but you really did feel
like you were part of them you know if
the other extreme was going to companies
like daimler-benz and at the time I was
an American employee of what was a
German company they didn't offer a lot
of stock to just normal employees
research scientists managers that wrong
the American side and at the same time
the culture was very interesting to work
with because again the headquarters was
in Germany so you know how did we
communicate with the Germany on a
regular basis and this was about 10
years ago so it was get on the phone
with them and that was always off hours
and it was very hard to just kind of
hang out with people it is hard to share
the informal culture that you really
want to build when you couldn't just
hang out there was no water cooler
between Germany and Silicon Valley so in
the companies you know I've created I've
had the opportunity to create direct
employee ownership getting stock options
to each of the employees that we brought
on and this is something that of course
in Silicon Valley's just expected what's
the more interesting issue for me is
then in the last 10 to 20 years as
technologies allowed us to change the
informal aspect of it so it 10 years ago
at the company we had if you wanted to
find out what everyone was doing you
came to the office today i have a small
company that you know we've been growing
pretty rapidly we actually have about
five or six offices around the country
however you want to measure it we have
one headquarters here in Silicon Valley
but only a small group of us actually
live in Silicon Valley the rest of us
live around the country and if you were
to go online right now you'd find that
we're all keeping in touch with each
other I know what people are playing for
music this morning I know what the
weather is like I know who has to run
off and help their kids
I know who has to has to get lunch
because we're able to keep in touch much
more easily across the time zones across
these distances and I think that's been
very interesting to say you can extend
the culture of a company very quickly
using a lot of these online tools
because the reason we have a company
spread out is that I want the best
people and the best people aren't always
located next to me it right now I have
to have them all domestically in the US
but there's no question right now we
work pretty regularly with Taiwan and
Shanghai and right now the question for
us is you know how do we extend our
culture of employment really to people
even if they're not in our company yet
but really trying to bring the middle of
a bit more help bring them into what we
can think of the Silicon Valley question
of ownership thank you so much so the
second question here is it meant to
generate a instant yes no reaction but
more to address a little bit about the
interplay between financial ownership
and psychological ownership because do
the workers need to own equity to feel
like they're part of an ownership
culture within a company and how do you
have approached this this concept with
your own company look there's no
question that if the employees own stock
in a company or owned some piece of it
they are owners of the company that said
though being part of the company is very
different I was an apple during the
heyday when you know owning part of the
company was great because the stock kept
going up and we all really felt like
we're part of the company and I was
there as part of it down turned before
jobs came back when AI still owned a lot
of stock but there was absolutely
nothing I could do to make that company
work the way I wanted it to I it was
getting too big it was going in
directions we couldn't control and it
became much more managerial in the sense
that it was bureaucratically couldn't do
anything so it's interesting that you
know you can have a definitive stock
ownership plan and yet really not be
creating another ship culture I know a
bunch of companies out here in Silicon
Valley that are consulting based firms
where the younger employees don't have
ownership of the company but they're so
vested in the company because the teams
bring them in managers are looking to
them that they actually do feel like
they're part of it and they know that if
they continue to
own the future of the company that
ultimately they will be brought into the
stock ownership as well as my last
question here as you're putting yourself
in the shoes of the CEO of the case and
of course looking at what your own
company is trying to do if you were to
open an office in China how would you
communicate this decision or prepare
your American team what are some the
considerations that you would keep in
mind you know Lauren talked a little bit
about some of the broader parameters
that define an employee ownership plan
you know as you think about your own
situation and team you know what would
you keep in mind and how would you kind
of have this this larger conversation
and to provide the environments to
encourage employee ownership so I don't
think it's really a question of hey that
we're adding a Chinese division and
everyone here says what the hell does
that mean I think it's just more
question of how are we going to
communicate with them the timezone is
offset it's pretty hard to work with
when you're sitting here in Silicon
Valley but everyone here is used to it
now where you're up in the morning to
talk to Europe and you're up late in the
evening to talk to Asia that's very
common but making sure that everyone in
the team understands that when we get up
when we stay up late and it impinges on
our dinner and it impinges on our late
night napping period the the Chinese
team is up early and they are just
getting around to the emails that we've
spent all day crafting so there needs to
be a real understanding I think actually
the Financial Times had an article just
a week or two ago that was discussing
this exact point which is as companies
are going more and more global where
it's not work being handed off around
the company around the globe but
actually teams working on coordinated
efforts around the globe you need to
just have the team understand if you
know who's up early who's up late and
making sure that that's over
communicated one of the pieces that's
most interesting to me that my team
would be food that would want to know is
how do we kind of just stay in touch
with them how do we know what they're up
to how do we make sure that if they have
a question they're willing to ask us
quickly the culture inside the company
we have now is that we live on skype
channels and we just leave them open all
day long and we like I said I know
who just ran out to lunch and I know
who's stuck in the rain and I know who's
got cold this morning because we keep
that moving around since we're not
seeing each other you know can we induce
the colleagues in China to have that
same openness not that we expect the
Chinese team not to be open we just need
to make sure they understand that that's
something we really use here to keep the
teams together since we're not going to
see each other on a regular basis but I
say the last piece is actually going to
be the question from my team is going to
be twofold and one of them is how do we
communicate with them and that's going
to be a language question and of course
that's always a fear when you're dealing
with other cultures of you know we speak
a very specialized version of American
English here in Silicon Valley a lot of
technical terminology a lot of jokes a
lot of work together for 20 years so we
all know the products and the companies
and the stores and restaurants how do we
bring the Chinese team into that given
we don't have the same shared interests
initially the other one is going to be
can they use the tools were using and
this is an issue of technology usage in
different countries just even latency
between the team the tools we use here
in Silicon Valley which happened to be
built and maintained a disturber down
the street and the fact that the guys in
Europe or the guise of South Africa or
the guys in China are going to be on
this massive delay that may cause
horrific problems they just don't want
to use the tools were using for
collaboration and we're very heavily
using distance tools so I think my team
would just have air e-course questions
just simple things and it's the same
question we'd asked we're going to add
another team member and say Canada or
New York just you know can I use the
tools how do we bring them into our
conversations how do we make sure they
feel like they're part of us thank you
and in many cases it really does come
down to a lot of these practical
considerations as we wrap up for those
who want to dig a little deeper into the
actual case that we describes you can
find it online at the aspen library in
particular there's a section called Clio
short for the curriculum library of
employer ownership where there is a fair
number of other resources and cases and
examples that delve into this particular
issue this particular case was funded by
the foundation for an enterprise
development
and the foundation for enterprise
development is one of the groups that
you could turn to if you have some
questions or would like to understand a
bit more about how you might like to
structure or evaluate employee ownership
and how that might fit what you're doing
either here in the US or abroad in China
or anywhere else you may be there's also
several books that you could look to so
there are five here that we've
identified that would be a good starting
point there certainly several others
that you might put on your bookshelf and
two of these here in particular the
guide to equity compensation and the
second one equity-based compensation for
multinational corporations is based on
research that Lauren is team have done
at the national center for employee
ownership so there's additional material
that you can find with and CEO and then
ultimately Lauren himself has made
himself available as an expert on call
so if you'd like to drill down a little
deeper on to some of the parameters or
examples that he gave please don't
hesitate to contact him and yeah here's
this information as well so with that in
mind I'd like to hand back to our team
at the Stanford center for professional
development and we can lead to any Q&A
thanks so much tamara and thanks for the
reminder so for folks in the audience
I'd encourage you to continue to submit
any questions that you have for Tamra
Dylan Lauren as I go through my my slide
deck here so at the Stanford center for
professional development we've been
delivering education to industry for
over 40 years and we have reasonable
experience in creating educational
programs to address the career long
learning needs of professionals managers
and executives and Industry we really
worked with faculty and departments to
deliver degree programs online as well
as develop graduate certificates from
most departments in the School of
Engineering here you can see the range
of fields from electrical engineering
and computer science to management
science and engineering and mechanical
engineering where the foresight program
that builds up
part of comes from the Stanford center
for professional development mission has
been to bring cutting-edge faculty
research and content to industry I'm
here you can see just a sample of our
non-credit intensive short courses that
we've developed over the years and they
really range from one hour long modules
to professional certificate programs
that require an application well we've
tried to do with our various programs is
to offer courses via flexible delivery
options so that students can either come
to stanford's campus and they can take
courses online via streaming video at
any time or we create customized and
tailored courses and workshops that can
be delivered at company work sites for
cohorts of 20 or more we've been hearing
about the challenges that executives
business leaders and decision-makers
face in terms of retooling and
revitalizing their enterprises for quite
a number of years and this has led to
are creating severoff several offerings
to equip folks with the problem-solving
tools and problem finding frameworks
that lead to innovation and strategic
leadership you'll see we have two
upcoming webinars on one of them has a
title at this moment of pivot thinking
when our neuro science of design we also
have our innovation master series I
design thinking in the art of innovation
occurring in June the 20th to the 22nd
and we've partnered with faculty from
the design group to create who's who of
masters class and design thinking in the
art of innovation and we're also very
excited to launch our innovation and
entrepreneurship online certificate the
first course will be coming in and
around the summer of 2012 so please stay
tuned for more details on that and I
just like to take a moment to conduct a
poll that I would really appreciate your
feedback on if you could indicate your
level of interest in the innovation
master series on the innovation and
entrepreneurship online certificate that
is new and upcoming and that would be
very much appreciated and we'll just
pause here for a moment I'm hoping to
get a few more questions and answers in
our sorry questions into the pipeline
here thank you so much for that feedback
and with that and I'd like to conduct a
few questions for for our colleagues
here so the first question that we
received is how much of a stock should
be in an equity compensation program I
can start with that there's no right
answer that one I'd say clearly there
are some wrong answers but I think what
the mistake that people make is they
start by thinking of percentage of the
company's stock that feels right and it
might be smarter to approach it the
other way around to look at it from the
employee perspective and say how much
from each employee's perspective is it
going to take to be motivating but not
be over motivating to to provide an
appropriate level of incentive without
going too far that'd be my ticket Thank
You Lauren so what are the statistics
regarding equity ownership for Chinese
employees of us-based companies what
percentage do it and if it's high what
forms are common I can answer that with
it i don't know i don't have that the
data point out the top of my head but i
know that some studies have delved into
that what we can do is gather some of
that information and provide that back
to the Stanford center for professional
development and make that available if
you're interested but certainly the
books and the different organizations
that we put on the reference page would
also be able to help point you to that
material but good question and one final
question and who decides how much each
employee gets that's also something that
varies from company to company I think
what's the more interesting question is
is whether it's going to be based on
discretion and have each award decided
by an individual person or whether
there's going to be some kind of
pre-established formula and I'd actually
love to hear what Bill and Tamara things
but I'm a big fan of the of the formula
because
people project and see if I do X then
I'll get why so it's a motivator in the
sense that it gives people a foreseeable
reward based on whether or not they can
reach some particular goals thank you so
much um would anyone like to add
anything yeah I would so in the
situation's I've worked in which was I
was on the receiving end in large
companies of stock grants I don't know
what the rules were and they were
transparent and I don't know if there
were rules and wasn't too clear me if I
could do anything to make that better
that was frustrating and I have yet to
see a company that really was strongly
rules based or outcome based at the
other end of that then in the company's
I've put together worth a very different
end of the spectrum worth small
companies growing larger we it's been
entirely my discretion as the person who
puts the team together and the person
who has the ultimate responsibility to
the board it's my job to decide what the
compensation rate looks like I which is
both salary and a mix of stock inclusion
and then figure out where that's going
to play out the issue we ask is i think
it was Tamara had slides early on with
you know here's the standard percentage
in a company that that's actually what
drives a lot of it you say to yourself
okay if I expect to have to use this
tranche of stocks let's say it's the
stock and made available in the first
round of funding to up to 15 to 20
employees and I want to be able to
compensate various levels which i think
i need to bring in some vice presidents
i need to bring in a chief and then the
rest of it it's going to be engineering
hires marketing hires and such the
bigger game is okay how do I make sure I
have enough stock that I don't run out
and yet I'm not left over with a pile of
stock so if you took cameras number and
ran them backwards I think it was
something like what twenty percent
whether people were compensated four
percent of the stock you can run the
numbers from that perspective and say
well that's it that gives you an
equation is the person's distributing
stock to say I need to make sure that if
I'm going to get up to 50 to 20
employees and I need to give out a
significant chunk of the first round of
this stock pool okay how much am I going
to get
each one I can't give one of them all of
it and have any left over that's kind of
a rule of thumb that out here in the
valley you learn from other people there
is no set rules of you know it isn't
written down anywhere but you just kind
of pick it up over time talking to other
people so that's really the best way to
learn is just start seeing what examples
exist have both the large and small
company level thank you Bill and I
believe Lauren has one question that he
would like to ask yes Kristen forever
you Tamara I thought your that for
decision point said the company was
facing was was a great way to frame the
issue I was wondering if the company had
considered doing any systematic way to
get input from employees in China as a
way to make that decision among those
four options great question so no
systematic way but instead more
indicative of I think the broader
culture here in Silicon Valley which is
through a lot of informal conversations
so I talked a little bit about how this
particular company CEO and caught up
with kind of friend of a friend chinese
national at the bar / happy hour to talk
a little bit about this but some of the
examples that bill highlighted around
the beer bashes at Apple you know the
other networking events that occur
pretty regularly here in Silicon Valley
now all of these are different occasions
to try and find out a little bit more
you know certainly the all of you who
are listening to this webinar the
Sanford Center for professional
development of different channels to try
and find out more information because
you know one of the big lessons that I
think you highlighted and certainly bill
touched on is that there's a little bit
more art than science to understanding
employee ownership and the best way to
learn is often from other entrepreneurs
and from other experts and the way to do
that of course is by reaching out
through your own network as well as
finding ways to try and connect to
bigger networks outside of yourself
through all different creative ways and
in doing so you essentially try and put
the pieces of a puzzle together to
understand a little bit more about you
know what you might do and this is very
much coming back to this particular case
what the CEO has been
to do now he has an advantage where one
of the investors happens to be embedded
in the Chinese community and the network
with in East Asia and so can also draw
on that as a resource to get some more
information and you know make sure that
he's not taking necessarily a very
Silicon Valley centric approach but also
even American driven approach and have a
company that ultimately is international
in nature and you know ultimately well
established to grow both in China but
anywhere else that makes sense for the
company is next steps so good question
well I'd like to take a moment to thank
Tamra Lauren and Bill this concludes our
webinar today as a reminder you may now
print a PDF of the slide by selecting
the print to PDF option remember to look
for an email that will alert you when
this webinar is available to watch
online I want to again thank you for
joining us and we see that there are a
few questions remaining in the queue and
we will stay in the live meeting room
until we've answered all of them for
those of you who have already had your
questions answered feel free to
disconnect thanks so much bye-bye